bonsoir à vous merci d'être avec nous
sur rt france en direct l'ensemble des
pays de l'union européenne qui doivent
être prêts pour la mise en place donc de
son pass and i ter sera le 17 juin
prochain c'est envisageable a selon vous
techniquement je ne sais pas
politiquement je suis tout à fait
sceptique
pourquoi et parce que si vous voulez on
a en 2018 je suis allé plaider au
parlement européen de la santé à
bruxelles sur un carnet de vaccination
électronique européen s'avère us avait
recueilli l'assentiment des gens c'était
une expérience qu'on avait lancé en
france et nul n'est prophète dans notre
pays
la cnam et le moyen on va dire de
récuser cet outil est quand même pas mal
si vous voulez qui a été adopté par le
grand duché du luxembourg et je suis
dubitatif si vous voulez sur ses
réalisations dans le délai imparti après
je rappelle quand même que on a tous
pour ceux qui voyagent beaucoup et en
particulier dans les destinations va
dire lointaine où la fièvre jaune la
fièvre mari qui a été vu à des instincts
virus découvert à dakar par l'institut
pasteur 1926 elle parle à tous incarnés
on va dire de vaccination jaune et noir
un passeport
ça ne pose aucun problème d'avoir ce
carnet de vaccination et je suis surpris
si vous voulez que l'état français
disent oh là là j'ai vite et puis
maintenant je suis comme thézac alors
que lorsque l'on vend aux baignades
otez moi d'un doute c'est quand même un
départ comme en outre-mer la guyane et
bien interactivement avoir ce passeport
si l'on vous raterez pas pire et c'est
vrai que lors d'un voyage dans certains
pays on ne peut pas y entrer si on n'a
pas à son terme et de vaccins avec la
pierre grise dans beaucoup de pays
africains notamment
ce passeport ce vaccinale vous pensez
que en france on en fait trop on débat
trop là dessus
inutile en oui très clairement si vous
voulez on nous aurait écouté honoré on
va dire à un carnet de vaccination
électronique on aura un registre
vaccinale on aurait une aide à la
décision
alors qu'on a un système canard boiteux
genre et sivac système informatique
vaccination qui comment pall
régulièrement où il n'y a pas de
collecte on va dire des données on va
dire de pharmacovigilance et d'effets
secondaires ou c'est indigents comme
système on a complètement raté le coche
en france le luxembourg a été tué dans
la probable demande aux états vont
suivent et d'autres sont des états de
par le monde en afrique en amérique du
sud après la france est en capacité
mais vous savez ce que c'est le vin fait
mitterrand france s'est il faut deux ans
et bien au 1er janvier 2022
l'outil qu'on a développés qui est on va
lire public internet vaccination
électronique avec un nid comme je peux
montrer qui correspond à on va dire à un
carnet de vaccination sera compatible
avec n'importe quel passeport vaccinale
donc le français qui a son carnet de
tina plus d'un million sera en capacité
on va dire de montrer sans l'état
vaccinal moi j'ai rentré par exemple que
j'ai une double vaccination je suis âgée
j'ai largement plus de 60
donc j'ai été vacciné au prevenar dès
début janvier quand vous c'est rentrer
les données temps je peux montrer le
code-barres c'est bon alors le problème
c'est que les campagnes de vaccination
elles sont inégales au niveau européen
en france ça avance a aussi un rythme
plutôt lent c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire donc c'est vrai que ça pose quand
même la question de des libertés
certains moments être les et d'autres
non je crois que c'est pas il faut pas
raisonner en termes de liberté où quand
je reprends l'exemple du passeport
papier noir et jaune
vous ne pouvez pas vous déplacer sur le
territoire français en guyane si vous
n'avez pas ce document vous ne pouvez
pas aller en afrique il n'y pas ce
document pouvait pas aller dans
certaines parties de l'asie du sud-est
en ce document c'est au contraire la
capacité de pouvoir se déplacer de nous
rendre notre liberté de voyage qui est
importante
je pense que c'est ça si vous voulez
après que l'on ait des sécurité on a
quand même l'air gpd on a des lois de
sécurité avec la cnil qui sont quand
même trapu en europe et en france comme
ça c'est vraiment pas un souci pour moi
par contre ce que les français veulent
c'est réellement pouvoir voyager et être
protégés et je suis d'accord avec vous
sur la vaccination avec on va dire le
recul colonna de l'acceptation de
l'astra et nectar
on est en train de couler on veut dire
la campagne vaccinale à terme si on
trouve pas de solutions de remplacement
il y en a pas il n'y a pas de vaccin
disponibles sur ce pass sanitaire
justement jean castex et de la évoqué ce
matin il a évoqué son utilisation pour
l'entrée à des concerts ou à des
événements sportifs vont se sera soumis
de toute façon c'est une décision qui
sera soumise aux parlementaires mais est
ce que la communication justement
gouvernementales à propos de ce pass
sanitaire parce que cela pose des
questions aussi à beaucoup d'hésitation
on avance on recule
oui mais chercher francion ça vous
surprend
sincèrement vous pouvez pas rentrer dans
une salle du cinéma dans un dindon stade
pour aller voir un match
mon équipe l'ol fut lyonnais groupama
stadium si j'ai pas mon billet avec monk
otmar c'est pas choquant si je dois
pouvoir voir mes amis et on va écrire
pouvoir voyager c'est pas choquant la
barre comment on va perdre pratiquement
une heure pour contrôler mes bagages
mais en plus cela va me prendre dix
secondes de montrer un code-barres que
j'aurais peut-être enfin sur mon
téléphone portable
moi ça me choque pas après que melody
soient effacées à la fin du vol je
trouve ça normal
c'est vrai qu'il ya des sondages qui
montrent que les français sont pas
forcément favorables à la mise en place
d'un pass a notamment oui mais
rappelez-vous une chose madame c'est que
les français n'étaient pas favorables à
la vaccination
et dieu sait si on a eu un retard à
l'allumage
je vous rappelle quand même que nos
autorités publiques ont quand même
commencé à se préoccuper d'un carnet de
vaccination de la vaccination à
l'automne 2020 or on était en zone 2 co
vite depuis janvier 2001 ils ont
réellement se préoccuper de ce schéma là
en octobre novembre
on allait d'un qu'on a les documents
pour ça bon si à ce moment là la
population française elle était jusqu'à
l'été dernier contre la vaccination
ils ont basculé pour la vaccination et
maintenant qu'est-ce qui nous disent
mais je veux pas d'astrazeneca moi j'ai
des confrères qu'il n'y j'ai deux
flacons en main frigo je sais pas quoi
faire on n'arrive pas à les vacciner
pourquoi parce qu'on a eu une volte face
on va dire volte face on va dire
sur le modèle de l'allemagne et c'est
toujours le même problème en france
c'est à dire l'absence de prise de
responsabilité de risque politique
j'ai peur du procès donc hommage au
suspens pendant trois jours et ça ça tu
es la machination
je rappelle qu'astrazeneca ses 25% des
doses en france jusqu'à la fin juillet
donc on est mal merci beaucoup à vous
pierre jeantet remaniant président urs
scheuss médecins libéraux auvergne
rhône-alpes